and then what about like institutions as
they come into this like are they
looking at this all just from like a
speculation standpoint are they trying
to build assets institutions let's
define the institutions i mean there are
two types of institutions there are like
financial services institutions kind of
what we've been talking about because
the d5 been but there's also you know
just enterprises or adidas nike whatever
so on the uh financial institutions you
know they're very aware that
the power of the blockchain or the
crypto
system is that when you need information
and money
to move at the same time
um it blockchain is a very powerful tool
for that so
the
when you settle a stock there are so
many intermediaries when you we talked
about swift early there's so many
intermediaries credit cards there's so
many intermediaries and they're all
working off of their own respective
databases and lots of reconciliation has
to happen
a lot of the financial services players
are actually
um
experimenting with blockchain the amount
of experimentation of blockchain
development not just experimentation
innovation labs but the amount of
development whether it's jpm coin you
know monetary authority singapore or dbs
with jpm trying to tokenize wholesale
lending um
city doing the um custody recently sat
gen you know working with maker dow they
are looking at it as a way the
technology as a way to create efficiency
and create more productivity and squeeze
costs out so that's one part of the
equation for institutions the other part
of institutions is really new business
models new business models that will
enhance user experience
brave uh brave browser for instance i
think you know it's been around for a
long time so i'm sure you know then your
audience knows it too but i think it's
kind of cool that
they protect you and your privacy they
don't allow your digital fingerprint or
your digital traversing of the internet
to just be sold you have to actually opt
into that so once you opt into that then
you can get paid in basic attention
tokens so you actually decide on your
privacy you then you own your data and
in other words like
tokenization and this whole new world
for institutions will change because the
users will now be at some point will be
able to basically turn their searching
into an asset via tokenization and
get the choice of privacy or
monetization